so let's talk a little bit about
financial institutions there are many
different types of financial
institutions but probably the most basic
one that almost everyone encounters at
some point in their life is a bank at a
bank at the most basic level there's
many things that a bank can do but it's
a place where you can deposit your money
arguably for safe keeping and a place
where you can access it easily and maybe
you're going to be able to get a little
bit of interest on it and so think about
what the world would be like if you did
not have Banks you would probably put
your money stuff it into your mattress
put it in a vault to some place one it
could be a little bit scary if someone
were to break into your house and I
think more people would break into
houses if they knew that people were
stuffing money into their mattress but
even more than that if you were to then
go make a big purchase of some kind
instead of handing someone your debit
card or being able to do it in an
electronic way you would have to take
all the cash there which by itself could
be a security issue and and frankly
it'll be hard to keep track of all of
that and so modern Banks you're able to
make your deposits the money is
accessible you with a debit card you can
log online use the various apps and see
what your different transactions have
been how much
um and and and and what your what Your
balances are wherever you are many times
in the world I was just out of the
country and uh with my debit card I was
able to go and get cash I was able to
buy things I didn't have to take all of
that cash with me on a plane now the
other thing that Banks do is they'll
give you interest and the way that they
are able to create that interest is they
take a large fraction of the the money
that's deposited and then they will lend
it out to other folks now if you have
less than 250 000 per person per account
type in a U.S Bank that's insured so you
can feel pretty confident that you put
that money in there if you need that
money you'll be able to take it out so
you don't have to worry too much about
that dimension of it and once again by
putting it in the bank versus is having
it stuffed in your mattress you're going
to be able to get some interest on it
and be able to access things very easily
now there are other financial
institutions there are things like
insurance companies we talk a lot about
insurance in this course and in order to
get insurance you need someone to take
the other side of it so you need someone
to pay a certain premium a certain
amount per month or per year to agree
that hey we got your back if the bad
thing were to happen and not just anyone
could start an insurance company or a
bank for that matter they're heavily
regulated because the government we all
want to make sure that these other
groups these other institutions are
going to be there for you when you need
it when you go to a bank you say I want
my money back they better give you your
money back if you go to an insurance
company and say hey look my car got
totaled I need the money back you better
hope that that insurance company is
there and that they're going to be good
for your money now there's many other
types of financial institutions and some
of them are connected or parts of
insurance companies or Banks you could
have things like brokerages these are
folks who help broker transactions
oftentimes it's a stock brokerage
they're helping if someone is buying a
stock that means that someone else is
selling that stock and a few times it's
the actual company that's selling the
stock but usually you're just buying it
from somebody else out there in the
stock market so you need the brokers who
help facilitate that transaction you
have the stock markets themselves that
obviously help or or in an even more
direct way I should say help make those
transactions happen as well so I could
go on and on and on we could spend hours
talking about all the different types of
financial institutions but it's
important to realize when you're using
your money or when you're interfacing
with any of these you're like okay what
does this organization do what am I
really getting out of it what are they
providing for me and then what are the
risks involved and what are what are
they getting out of it how do they make
their money and is that something that I
think is a reasonable thing for them to
do given the services that they're
providing to me